the city of gerlichs is gearing up to
fight back these residents have gathered
to protest the announcement that Siemens
plans to close its plant here the
company is one of the biggest employers
in the region workers say the decision
to close the factory makes no sense
then a scuba a 22 year veteran at the
girl its plants agrees there's plenty of
work that's piling up we're preparing
many new bids for various projects to
make sure the orders keep coming in
there are lots of interesting projects
out there in renewable energy the solar
market looks especially promising and
we're pursuing all of that so there's no
shortage of work
definitely not there's no reason to shut
this plant no there is integrant Siemens
began building large steam turbines in
Girl it's in the early 1990s a few weeks
ago the company announced that it plans
to shut the plant by 2023 since the
announcement technical project manager
of n h2 burner has been helping to
organize the workers response we're not
allowed in what's the mood in the plant
mood is fairly tense but the workers are
prepared to fight back around 900 people
work in the plant stood nur worked his
way up from industrial mechanic to
project director he has three children
so where are we going we're going to
brief us an industrial printer they're a
supplier for our turbine operation here
in girl it's the Basit brevis is
supporting us in our labor dispute and
printed two banners for us we've now had
another one printed that we'll be using
in our candlelight vigil tonight across
the region around 150 companies and
vendors supply siemens with products and
components most support the protests
that's great size is perfect too we're
planning to go big with this keep girl
it's a live logo make it a kind of
trademark on everything we use you're
also Siemens supplier yes we are a major
customer yes they are what will happen
if the Siemens plant here closes it
would be a huge blow for the region and
for us our sales would drop will you
have to let people go
via must some kind of expense we won't
have to let people go
no we have a wide range of products and
a broad range of customers we might end
up seeing the departure of some highly
skilled workers and we might see some
mid-sized companies some suppliers
cutting their workforces
Reavers produces stainless-steel labels
for industrial components the
unemployment rate in girl it is 14%
something that's not evident at first
glance to outsiders girl it's has been
burnished and renovated much of it with
the help of subsidies that went to the
former East Germany after German
reunification big companies moved into
the area and brought jobs Siemens was
one railway and Aeronautics engineering
firm Bombardier another but now they too
planned to cut about a thousand jobs
what will that mean for the region if
major industrial operations like Siemens
and Bombardier leave the region it would
be a real blow but as a city's business
manager I haven't given up hope the past
two months we've had huge numbers of
inquiries from investors the news of
what's happening here has made headlines
outside the region now companies from
Germany and even international companies
have been contacting us potential
investors are keeping us very busy in NH
to blur and his colleagues at Siemens
planned to keep fighting for their jobs
but they've heard that investors are
already beginning to approach the highly
skilled workers who would be thrown back
onto the job market if the plant closes
inquiries are coming from the automotive
and logistics industries what's more
Gurlitt still qualifies for substantial
government subsidies up to 40% of
investment costs so there's still hope
the lights will keep burning in girl
it's
you